[Música]
ah
i
soy de cali colombia
una ciudad de 2.5 millones de habitantes
ubicada en el sur occidente del país
con una temperatura promedio de 27
grados celsius durante el año
al pie de la cordillera de los andes
capital de un departamento que tiene mar
páramo ríos selvas
y un valle que nos da árboles frutales y
productos agroindustriales cali pasa de
mil a cuatro mil metros de altura en su
territorio y es hogar para más de 500
especies de aves
tal y como ciudad ha sido pionera en las
artes y la cultura de colombia
y desde hace más de 100 años es lugar de
recibo para múltiples nacionalidades y
razas lo que hace que la diversidad de
culturas haya sido una parte muy
importante de nuestra historia y nuestro
presente
cali es conocida como la sucursal del
cielo la sultana del valle la capital
deportiva de américa o capital mundial
de la salsa y alcanzó a ser descrita por
el poeta eduardo carranza como un sueño
atravesado por un río
tengo 42 años nací y crecí en cali en
los años 70 80 y 90
justo en estas décadas en este paraíso
que les estoy contando que es cali
tuvimos un flagelo que se apoderó de
muchas de los estamentos de la ciudad
desafortunadamente el narcotráfico
y esto hizo y estoy seguro que esto que
voy a decir también lo recuerdan los
muchos de los cientos de miles de
personas que hoy tenemos 30 40 50 años y
es como el universo de palabras asociado
a cali por lo menos cuando yo crecí no
eran cordillera
aves valle árboles sino más bien
carteles corrupción narcotráfico
violencia
por supuesto que había otras palabras
asociadas a la ciudad como salsa o
fútbol pero incluso estas fueron
acalladas en algún momento por la fuerza
con la que irrumpió el narcotráfico en
nuestras vidas
ese universo de palabras es un universo
conceptual
ese relato ese imaginario terminó
convirtiéndose en una parte muy
importante de nuestra reputación como
ciudad
la buena noticia es que paralelo a esta
realidad había otra realidad y sigue
habiendo esta otra realidad
una realidad innegable que no ha hecho
parte tan importante del imaginario de
los caleños
hechos como que cali fue la primera
ciudad con un museo de arte moderno en
el país donde se fundaron las bases del
nuevo teatro latinoamericano se fundó la
primera escuela de ballet profesional se
hicieron las primeras películas la
primera película color y la primera
película con sonido y hay en cali el
valle del cauca
más de 13.000 empresas creativas que
mueven 5 billones de pesos al año
o más hechos como las más de 120
escuelas de salsa o las 40 festivales
culturales que ocurren cada año en
nuestra ciudad entre los que entre los
que podemos destacar el petronio álvarez
el festival de cultura afro más
importante de latinoamérica o la feria
de cali que anualmente atrae más de un
millón de visitantes éstas también son y
siguen siendo realidades innegables de
nuestra ciudad
la verdad es que cali hoy es una ciudad
diferente es obvio que tenemos
muchísimos retos sociales económicos y
tenemos muchas oportunidades de mejora
en la calidad de vida de todos los
caleños pero si nos remitimos a cifras
como la reducción de pobreza la
reducción en la tasa de homicidios y el
crecimiento económico
podemos entender que cali hoy es una
ciudad que se transformó en los últimos
10 años
sin embargo muchas de las conversaciones
que tenemos los caleños alrededor de
nuestra ciudad
por ejemplo en digital
tienen que ver o están anclados a
imaginarios del pasado o tienen que ver
con temas más bien funcionales como ir a
cine el pico y placa o el fútbol
no hay nada malo en revisar la cartelera
de cine para ver qué película quiero
disfrutar con mi familia o pasar un buen
rato viendo un partido pero la pregunta
es teniendo cali esta cultura y
creatividad tan presentes no estaría
bueno que la conozcamos que nos la
podamos apropiar y la podamos disfrutar
decíamos que la reputación de la ciudad
eso que se dice y se piensa de uno
es parte de los imaginarios y los
relatos y a eso nos dedicamos las
personas que hacemos publicidad a
mejorar la reputación de nuestros
clientes
por eso cuando en 2016 la alcaldía de
cali y la cámara de comercio de cali nos
pidieron que les ayudaremos a encontrar
una estrategia que mejorará la
reputación de cali entendimos que había
que darle todo un canal de comunicación
a esta realidad cultural y creativa de
nuestra ciudad
entendiendo también que una percepción
no se cambia a punta de slogans ni a
campañas publicitarias y que es más bien
un trabajo de medio plazo de mediano
plazo
creamos cali creativa la plataforma de
marca y reputación de ciudad que impulsa
las industrias culturales y creativas de
cali y el valle del cauca
en cali creativa
un equipo multidisciplinario de
periodistas videógrafos sociólogos
diseñadores por supuesto publicistas
investigamos producimos y publicamos
todos los contenidos que tienen que ver
con cultura y creatividad bien sea que
son producidos en la ciudad o por
caleños en bogotá o en el exterior
a la fecha llevamos publicados más de
1000 contenidos en tres años y hemos
logrado que un millón 200 mil personas
interactúen con nuestras publicaciones
2.3 millones de veces igualmente
contamos con 70 mil seguidores en
nuestras redes sociales y 25 mil
personas nos visitan mensualmente en
nuestra página web
todos estos contenidos son las noticias
que producen
los miles de chefs arquitectos músicos
artistas plásticos diseñadores
industriales bailarines directores
productores gestores culturales y
eventos de la ciudad de esta naturaleza
ya que tenemos cubierto el capítulo
digital por cierto espero que nos
empiecen a seguir hoy los que aún no nos
conocen
queríamos también que los medios de
comunicación ayudaran a replicar este
mensaje y es así como también hace tres
años iniciamos una relación con medios
de comunicación locales nacionales e
internacionales para que nos ayudaran a
replicar este mensaje a replicar esta
narrativa desde desarrollos tecnológicos
que como bien vimos hoy están sucediendo
en nuestra ciudad
hasta la oportunidad que tuvimos este
año de que el petronio álvarez fuera
parte de una de las noticias de
periódicos de europa y eeuu
de igual manera establecemos relaciones
permanentes con líderes creativos de
cali colombia para que nos ayuden a
replicar este mensaje y hacer
embajadores de esta cali creativa
también hemos hecho alianzas con más de
30 instituciones y medios de
comunicación para apoyar programas de
difusión y desarrollo empresarial para
las industrias culturales y creativas
apoyamos activamente la agenda cultural
de la ciudad no solamente con la
temporada de festivales de cali que es
una estrategia que une los 12
principales festivales culturales de la
ciudad en un solo canal de comunicación
sino también con nuestro con nuestra red
de 100 gestores culturales que
semanalmente nos informan de los eventos
que se están llevando a cabo en la
ciudad que por cierto son entre 30 y 40
eventos culturales semanales en cali
finalmente para poder aportar con un
espacio de conexión y que ayudará
también al desarrollo empresarial al
mismo tiempo que contribuye a esta
narrativa positiva sobre la ciudad
creamos el mec movimiento de empresas
creativas no solamente con la alcaldía y
la cámara de comercio de cali sino
también con la gobernación del valle y
el ministerio de cultura
y en el mec los empresarios creativos y
las personas afines a la cultura y la
creatividad podemos encontrar talleres
charlas espacios de conexión exhibición
de arte conciertos de música
traemos compradores y hemos generado
también
transacciones y ventas para músicos y
artistas plásticos de la ciudad y de la
región
más de 400 líderes creativos de nueva
york londres méxico puerto rico buenos
aires-madrid bogotá
por supuesto cal y han pasado por el mec
y no solamente nos dejan sus
experiencias sino que también ayudan a
ser embajadores de esta cali creativa
hoy tres años después más de mil
emprendedores beneficiados más de ocho
mil asistentes al mes más de 400 líderes
creativos que nos han acompañado más de
50 medios nacionales e internacionales
que aportan a la conversación creando un
free press' de más de un millón de
dólares más de 1.3 millones de personas
interactuando en digital 3 festivales de
creatividad y desarrollo empresarial
y otros hitos
podemos afirmar con toda seguridad que
la cultura y la creatividad en cali cada
vez tienen un espacio más importante
dentro de nuestro relato dentro de
nuestro imaginario queremos que cada vez
nos acompañe más gente
en cali estamos trabajando muy duro
para poder superar narrativas del pasado
y poder superar titulares como este que
ya no nos representa
a este hace tan solo tres semanas
gracias a un trabajo de un equipo el
cual orgullosamente pertenezco en la
alcaldía de cali logramos que la unesco
reconociera a cali como una de las
ciudades creativas del mundo la primera
en suramérica de artes digitales
[Aplausos]
el filósofo israelí noa harary nos habla
de cómo el lenguaje apareció en la
especie humana no solamente para poderle
avisar al vecino que ahí viene un león
sino también como fuente de chismorreo
es decir construcción de confianza y
tejido social
el primero de los acuerdos toltecas nos
invita a ser impecables con las palabras
que usamos porque entre otras cosas
aquello que decimos puede convertirse en
realidad
las palabras crean conceptos los
conceptos crean narrativas y una vez las
narrativas se afianzan cambian
realidades transforman realidades
la manera en la que nosotros como
caleños decidamos definirnos a nosotros
mismos va a marcar la diferencia del
tipo de sociedad que queremos construir
en cali queremos superar las narrativas
del pasado y queremos construir unos
nuevos relatos que estén a la altura de
lo que queremos ser como sociedad
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]